bye lyman hi
[Music]
pucker up mother
my partner has never yelled at a
television set as much as he did
yesterday with your elimination thank
you guys
endlessly for everything i'm forever
grateful
oh i'm gonna be bitter forever
i feel great there's been such a you
know i have
so many messages and so much love and so
much support and so many people
uh like your partner who are screaming
at the tv
so i'm i'm i'm feeling a lot of love
today i feel great i feel gorgeous
and i feel amazing there was no question
in my mind
that this was going to be a double
[Music]
chanted
so when that didn't happen i was
completely
shook that was an incredible lip sync
you two did congratulations on that
there was a lot of drama this season
surrounding
lemon i think that you
come off as not genuine and you want to
be
the perfect person and i feel like i
haven't really got to know
the real you i think sometimes um
confidence can be seen as arrogance and
those are two completely
different things do you feel that queens
were
really just threatened by lemon yes that
is definitely part of it
i also think it's you know they all knew
each other they were all
canadian queens and almost all of them
had worked together
a couple times if not frequently um and
i was kind of the one person who no one
knew anything about
and i was you know doing very well so i
think it was very
uh probably annoying the drama squash
we're all good pals now we're all good
judy's good sisters like at the end of
the day there's only 12 people who can
understand
what being in that work room the first
day was like you did
such an incredible job in snatch games
i am so excited to be here at the snatch
game i am so excited to live my truth
and what truth would that be that i
can't pronounce my oz
thank you thank you brooklyn i have
interviewed jojo siwa before
and you had her mannerisms down
like to a t like you were jojo siwa
honestly i was terrified to do snatch
game it's
so intense it's so scary but i think the
three red bulls just turned me into jojo
and
i'm gonna have to say they really do
give you wings
and having herbo tweet about it like
were you just like oh my gosh what a
moment
well i like i think jojo is like the
next paw princess like i think
she's gonna take her millions of
tiny little fans and as they grow up she
is going to dominate pop music
or whatever she wants to do honestly
there has been a big debate
online in the twitter verse of you know
judges critiques
had you done like a high-waisted baggy
pant and then i cinched in corset over
top of that
lost the chunky boot and done a
sickening stiletto with like a purse
with all that with like a gold chain
belt so completely different
completely different there were moments
where you walked out on the runway and
you sold
everything where i was like are we
seeing the same thing here
there's no right or wrong in drag it's
all it's
it's all opinion and it's like that for
most art
and so i'm used to you know
having my own artistic opinion and then
also benefiting
from a judge's point of view so i don't
find
you know at the end of the day also
they're asked to be making good tv
too and was it not the best tv ever last
night was such a special episode with
rainbow railroad
that was incredible lime is an angel on
this earth
this is the moment we met just the
kindest sweetest energy this
the nicest person ever and getting to
hear
lime's story and everything that
you know she went through before she got
to come to canada was
was really you know life-changing
honestly it was very eye-opening
i feel like you see numbers a lot
but to like put a face to put faces
to those numbers just reminds you of
like how
serious this is and how like there's
real people that need help it's
wonderful to see that your drag means a
lot more than
you know dress up or doing the splits
and and to really feel that your drag
all of our drag can change people's
lives is is really really
really wonderful oh
hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click
subscribe or watch these videos